i apologize ahead of time but let me ask
you the internet question so you're a
physicist you ask
rigorous questions about the physics of
existence and
these models of high assembly objects
now when the internet would see an alien
they would ask two questions
one can i eat it and two can have sex
with it
yes so
questions those are very the ancient is
very sophisticated
so it really is our basal cognition
pretty pretty good
so you kind of mentioned that it's very
difficult it's possible that we may not
be
even able to communicate with it right
but i think the internet has more hope
than we do
yes it's a hopeful place yes uh do you
do you think in terms of like
interacting on this very primal level of
of sharing resources like what would
aliens eat what would we eat would we
eat the same thing would could we
potentially eat each other
one one person eats the other or or the
aliens eat us
and the same thing with not sex in
general reproduction but genetically
mixing stuff
like would we would be able to mix
genetic information
maybe not genetic but maybe information
right and i think part of your question
is like
so so if you if you think of life as
like this history
of events that happen in the universe
like there's this question of like how
divergent are those histories
right so when we get to the scale of
technology it's possible imagine
imagine although we can't even do it
like imagine all the possible
technologies that could exist in the
universe but if you think about all the
possible chemistries somehow that seems
like a lower dimensional space and a
lower set of possibilities
so it might be that like when we
interact with aliens
we do have to go back to those more
basal levels to figure out sort of what
the map is
right um like the sort of where we have
a common history
we all we must have a common history
somewhere in the universe
but in order to be able to actually
interact in a meaningful way you have to
have some shared history i mean the
reason we can exchange genetic
information in each other's food
or eat each other as food um is because
we have a shared history
so we have to find that shared history
the other we have to find the common
ancestor in this causality map
yes and we have a last universal common
ancestor for all life on earth which i
think is sort of the nexus of that
causality map for life on earth
but the question is where would other
aliens diverge
on that interesting and i mean that
so say there's a lot of aliens out there
in the universe each
each set of organisms will probably have
like a number you know like erdos number
of like how far
like how far our common ancestor is and
so the closer the common ancestor like
it is on earth
the more like each other the more likely
we are to be able to have
sexual reproduction well it's like sort
of like humans having common culture and
languages right
yeah exactly communication it might take
a lot of work though with an alien
because you really have to get over a
language barrier
oh boy so it says communication it's uh
resources i mean the whole
and i think tied into that is the
questions of like who's going to harm
who
right and actually definitions parents
approve you know all those kind of
questions
whether the common ancestor approves
yeah it's just very true
you